FABIAN TAMP: Hi, I'm Fabian.
I'm a software engineer on the
Android and Google Maps teams.
My team's been working
on getting the Google
Apps that you know and
love into your car.
And we're really excited
about Android Auto,
because it combines the best
of the hardware in your car
with the upgradability,
connectivity,
and personalization of
your Android smartphone.
Your car is by far the
most complicated accessory
that we've ever attached
to an Android phone
before, with a vast
number of sensors
and some serious
audiovisual capabilities.
Let's start with the
Android Auto protocol,
which enables your
phone to talk to a car.
One of the biggest features
of the architecture
is that Android apps and
services run entirely
on your phone whilst being
controlled using your car.
We run the applications
into a compressed video
stream and audio
streams and send them
across to the head unit.
Typically, cars
are kept for longer
and get software updates less
frequently than smartphones.
So by shifting the
processing and rendering over
to the phone, we can take
advantage of the latest
mobile technology and keep
your Android Auto experience
up-to-date over the
life of your car.
We wanted to make the Android
Auto protocol easy to integrate
with cars, so we provide
manufacturers with a portable
C++ library that runs
on Linux, Android,
and QNX within the
car's head unit.
The core metaphor that the
Android Auto protocol uses
is [? one ?] to
prioritize channels.
Different channels are open
for the different aspects
of your car that the phone
needs to communicate with.
Channels are open for audio,
for display data, user input
and location data, like
GPS and wheel speed.
These channels
multiplex together
over the USB
connection, which allows
us to give priority to
the channels that affect
the experience the most.
We've built this protocol on top
of the Android Open Accessory
protocol, but designed it
to be transport agnostic.
So we can open it up to
other forms of connectivity,
such as Wi-Fi Direct,
in the future.
To format data, we use
protocol buffers extensively.
Protocol buffers are an open
source Google technology
that makes it really
convenient to add new features
in the future whilst retaining
backwards compatibility.
A key design goal
for us was to make
Android Auto feel like it fits
in with the rest of your car.
In version one,
we've got support
for different input methods,
specifically for touch screens
and for hard rotary
controllers, in a similar way
to how the standard Android
UI supports both touch
and controller modes.
We're also supporting
turn instructions
on instrument clusters that
can display them and integrate
with the buttons on
your steering wheel,
where they're available.
We also support routing
audio to different speakers
within the car, based
on the type of audio.
For example, navigation
instructions in Google
Now can be targeted
just to the driver,
whilst music gets played over
all the speakers in the car.
There's invariably going to
be times when you're listening
to the radio and want to ask
Google Now to read a message,
for example.
So the car and the phone
negotiate audio focus
in a similar way to how apps
negotiate on an Android phone.
The car has the ultimate say
on when Android Auto is visible
or playing audio,
so it can ensure
that safety critical
notifications
and the reversing camera,
for example, get priority.
On the phone side, we're
building the Android Auto code
into Google Play services,
so your experience
can be kept up-to-date.
The Android Auto system uses
the Android virtual display API
extensively.
Let's dive in and take a
look at the rendering system.
In Android Auto, rendering
occurs across app process
boundaries onto a common
surface for the car screen.
We use XML to define
a layout of windows
to be rendered by
different apps.
There is a window
for the navigation
rail, for the main content
area, for the notification area,
and one for the
search space as well.
Each of these
windows is actually
an android.view.TextureView.
The Android Auto service
takes the TextureViews back
into SurfaceTexture, wraps
it in a surface object,
and passes it to the client
process over a [? binary ?]
interface.
Within the client library,
a private virtual display
is created from that surface,
and the applications UI
is inflated into
the virtual display.
We then render the XML layout
to compress frames using
another virtual display, backed
by the phone's hardware video
encoder, and send the
output to the head unit.
There's two core principles
behind this architecture.
The first is flexibility.
Using TextureViews
in an XML layout
allows us to lay out
the windows arbitrarily.
That means we can take advantage
of the full Android layout
system, including animations.
The second is security
and stability.
By keeping clients rendering
in their own process,
we can isolate problems from the
rest of the system and ensure
the apps don't have access to
any data that they shouldn't.
Also, we want to make sure
that existing apps on the phone
can take advantage of the
improved location signals that
are available from the car.
So we've rolled these signals
into Google Play Services'
Fused Location Provider.
The Fused Location Provider
combines the different location
technologies available on
an Android smartphone--
cellular signal,
Wi-Fi, and GPS--
into a single high-level
API that allows developers
to specify accuracy requirements
and update frequencies,
instead of dealing with
individual location sources.
By adding location
sources from the car,
we're enhancing the accuracy
of location data using APIs
that apps are already using.
So now, I'm going to
talk to you about how
we've used Android Auto
and the Google Maps app
to enhance the
in-car experience.
First of all, Google
Maps is so much easier
to use for navigation when
it's on a large screen, front
and center, instead
of on a tiny phone
screen in a mount
on your dashboard.
We've redesigned Maps
to work beautifully
in a horizontal aspect ratio,
and optimized the UI for use
in car-- for example, by
minimizing task completion
times and making the
touch targets easy to hit.
One of the biggest advantages
of automotive Google Maps
is that using the Fused
Location Provider,
we can use the GPS data from
your car, which vastly improves
the location quality when
city driving, for example.
We can also use your car's
compass, gyroscopes, wheel
speed, and other positioning
sensors to work out
which way you're facing,
and exactly how far you've
traveled through that tunnel.
All of this allows us to
give you much more accurate
driving directions to get you
to your destination with less
hassle.
So that's an overview
of how Android Auto uses
the technology on your
Android phone and in your car
together to create a
great driving experience.
We're really excited
for the potential
that Android Auto has to
make in-car entertainment
and navigation more seamless,
connected, and safe.
Thanks for watching.